[Music]
I'm very happy for them we were sweet
people dr. oz opens up about Katy Perry
and Orlando Bloom's romance after
spending time with the pair in Vatican
City from your vantage point do they
look as smitten as ever yes his folks
are in love and they were on the same
wavelength we were talking to them after
one of the dinners and it was
fascinating because they get each other
they understand each other and they
speak as a couple at least my wife when
I were walking with them they were just
beautiful to see
et spoke with the famous doc backstage
at the 2018 Daytime Emmy Awards right
after he took home the trophy for
outstanding informative talk show to be
recognized in this way the by the
Academy I know you're a humble and
gracious man but how good does that feel
it it's orgasmic I woke up this morning
with my wife next to the Vatican I was
with the Pope yesterday because there
was an ethics and medicine conference
and I feel passionately about that but I
wanted to be here so much that I
basically took a tour of European
capitals pinging around trying to get
back here in time I came right from the
airport that's how much this matters to
me how will you celebrate we're gonna go
in and not burger you have shakes you
got the double-double go for the extra
panel is worth it I really
[Music]
[Applause]